bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour cette foire aux questions stop
science un fois en question pour
laquelle j'ai accueilli aujourd'hui
ronan allain prenant bonjour bonjour
donc ronan tu est maître de conférences
muséum au muséum d'histoire naturelle de
paris est chargée des collections du
musée et aujourd'hui on accueille dans
le contexte de notre série d'interviews
sur les dinosaures de france et on va
parler un petit peu aujourd'hui déjà de
ta carrière puisque dans durant ta
carrière tu as eu l'occasion d'étudier
de nombreux spécimens de dinosaures
français et on va aussi évidemment par
les deux ans jacques puisque tu es le
comment le directeur des fouilles c'est
ça ouais je coordonne je coordonne un
petit peu les fouilles au niveau
scientifique pour dire les choses les
choses comme elles sont prêts c'est vrai
que sur la fouille elle même on érige en
français tournepiche on est on est tous
les deux vraiment entre logistique et
coordination scientifique d'accord
coordinateur des fous ou alors première
question un peu à peu classique
comment tu en est venu à la
paléontologie sa tête est venu sur le
taux sur le tard alors la paléontologie
par oui ou par goût ça m'est venu sur
l'auto chebah je suis d'abord passée par
là les sciences de la terre puisque je
suis plutôt géologue de formation
donc j'avais quand j'étais on va dire
petit on tient bien les choses j'aimais
déjà pas mal tout ce qui avait trait à
l'archéologie mais aussi beaucoup s qui
était sciences de la terre et puis ils
ont ramassé des cailloux par terre donc
ça c'est des lycées c'est vrai une vraie
passion de deux petits garçons
et puis d'après au fur et à mesure au
cours de cours de mes études j'étais
plutôt porté sur les sciences finalement
que sur les matières littéraires donc je
me suis vraiment tourné vers l
anthologie plus que l'art qu'est
l'archéologie puisqu'à cette époque à
l'archéologie tu es vraiment une science
par laquelle on arrivait par le parrain
d'un cursus littéraire et puis ballongue
la géologie donc je me suis spécialisé
très vite puisqu'en paris 6 à jussieu
dès la deuxième année d'oeil à l'époque
avait pas encore de licence c'est la
deuxième année de licence pour nous
c'était la deuxième red dog on avait
déjà des spécialisations en
logique donc j'ai pu intégrer cette
spécialisation n'était déjà plus de 40
et puis j'ai eu la chance d'intégrer
l'année suivante le magistère
interuniversitaire donc avec j'étais
auditeur à l'école normale supérieure
sans être normalien et donc là on était
plus que 12 dans la promo donc c'est
vrai que des conditions assez
sympathique pour pour pour travailler et
puis voilà c'était c'était de la
géologie et surtout la géologie profonde
je veux dire c'était encore très accès
physique et géophysiques et et
mathématiques et j'avais toujours ce
côté un petit peu naturaliste et terrain
ce qui fait que j'étais plus intéressé
par des disciplines comme la pétrologie
la stratigraphie et la paléontologie
pour le peu qu'on en faisait et puis pas
de fil en aiguille quand on nous a
demandé de faire des stages de terrain
j'ai pu faire un premier stage de
paléontologie à montpellier avec
handicap et assure des requins et puis
l'année suivante
philippe taquet au muséum m'a proposé de
travailler sur les dinosaures du laos et
c'était il ya presque vingt ans par jour
pour jour mais à quelques mois près donc
ça fait 20 ans que j'ai commencé à
travailler au muséum mais j'ai réussi à
décrocher un poste donc en 2007 puisque
j'ai fait ma thèse en de 98 à 2002 sur
des dinosaures carnivores les mégalos
sort idée du jurassique d'europe et en
particulier de france avec la découverte
de débrouille aux russes et puis après
il ya eu comme tout le monde les années
un petit peu de je vais pas dire de
galère puisque c'est des années où on
est vraiment scientifiquement uni où on
travaille beaucoup donc c'est vraiment
la partie peut-être la plus sympa d'une
carrière au niveau scientifique mais
c'est peut-être la moins facile d'un
point de vue pécuniaire
donc voilà partie rejeté à ter à rennes
après gta ter à rouen après je suis
parti deux ans grâce à une bourse de la
de chez schubert j'ai de la fondation
des treilles puis de l'agencé
universitaire de la francophonie je suis
parti deux ans au maroc avec ma petite
famille et puis je suis rentré en france
un an
j'ai passé au chômage avant de réussir à
avoir un poste ô misère
et voilà donc depuis 2005 je suis maître
de conférences à paris au musée
donc tu as tu as travaillé en tant que
donc c'était pendant ta tête tu as
travaillé donc sur les mégalos szohr
idée d'europe et c'est là que tu as tu
nous as dit dubreu découvert enfin pas
découvert mais décrit dubreuil aux eaux
russes et il me semble que tu as aussi
travaillé sur pau équipe le redon c'est
sa politique et aux pleurotes kino
j'avais en fait j'avais qui n'osent hors
de france les premiers paraît première
premières études que j'ai fait c'était
sur la mosson qui a eu la description
avant d'un sauropode tant que vaille aux
russes
puis après effectivement ou travailler à
cette époque là sur le petit site
le tricycle grands sites qui se trouve
un bassin d'aix en provence à la bouche
hard et donc à la bouche arles on avait
une fois du crétacé supérieur assez
typique et au départ ma thèse devait
porter sur sur le rap de dons et puis en
fait bas à peu près au même moment il ya
eu d'autres découvertes de rap de don
particulier du côté du côté de
montpellier
et donc c'est marie mince micky a fait
sa thèse sur abdou donc il s'est trouvé
que que j'ai changé rapidement de sujet
de test n'est pas la peine de se mettre
à deux sur un même sujet de thèse donc
mari avait commencé un an avant moi et
puis non qu'on devait commencer sur les
faunes du crétacé supérieur de france de
théropode carnivore de france j'ai
réussi à décrire le petit le petit
baveux lapsus petit pierrot raptor donc
le petit drôme et aux ors du du bassin
d'aix-en-provence
et puis en fait un mois après le début
de ma thèse on est parti avec philippe
taquet donc effectivement en normandie
parce qu'on avait été appelée donc par
monsieur dubreuil qui avait fait une
découverte quelques années plus tôt on a
été sur le terrain est en fait en très
peu de temps d'une journée ou deux on
avait commencé à retrouver là la moitié
des restes d'un crâne de mégalo zor et
les mégalos zorn et pas été réétudié
depuis plus de presse qu'une
cinquantaine d'années où une soixantaine
d'années et surtout on n'avait jamais
retrouvé de matériel c'était assez
intéressant puisque c'est historiquement
les animaux
qui sont les premiers dinosaures décrit
puisque cuvier a décrit les premiers et
reste sans savoir de dinosaures d'un
point de vue scientifique en 1800 et
puis mégalo zaurus et le premier
dinosaure car sur un nom par buckland en
donc voilà il y avait cet aspect
historique qui était très croustillant
le fait de retrouver du matériel et puis
en plus du matériel qui est quand même
assez exceptionnellement bien préservés
et donc ça a été aussi une occasion de
réviser tout un tas de matériel et
comment y compris effectivement donc ce
très beau ce qu'on dit luce donc les
plusieurs reste que cuvier avait déjà
décrit en 1800 et j'en ai encore deux à
décrire la au bureau qui est qui qui
avait échappé un petit peu au aux
paléontologues donc on a retrouvé sa
reine du matériel supplémentaire
et puis donc payer kg pleut rome qui est
ce très beau dinosaures qui avait été
découvert par des longs champs en
normandie
donc dans les carrières de la maladrerie
et qui malheureusement a été détruit
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale par
les bombardements alliés sur caen avant
le débarquement et pollicino plus ron
heureusement il y avait des moulages
conservés au muséum à paris donc gérer
étudié en fait en partie ces essais nous
lâche
voilà donc à une révision vraiment
complète et intéressante à faire et puis
remettre au goût du jour un petit peu
les dinosaures carnivores jurassique
moyen c'est quand même une période
cruciale dans l'évolution des théropodes
puisque c'est la période où on va avoir
toutes les lignées de théropodes qui
s'individualise donc c'est une période
charnière dans l'histoire de l'évolution
des dinosaures donc puisqu'on est sur la
thématique des dinosaures français est
ce que c'est des dinosaures qui ont
foulé le sol français on va dire envoyer
mais il me semble qu'en normandie c'est
pas du matériel qui a charrié plutôt est
ce que c'est vraiment des choses qu'ils
vivaient localement alors au jurassique
moyen on est en le contexte le contexte
c'est on est en mer et puis continental
en fait l'europe est un archipel d'îles
et en fait les massifs les il ya les
parties émergées sont les grands massifs
donc le massif armoricain merci centrale
massif de londres et du brave ans après
on a un petit morceau de péninsule
ibérique sûrement est donc cet archipel
d'îles
on est vraiment mes répliques
continental donc des mères très très
haut fond d'une vais peut-être sans
doute via leurs possibilités des changes
à certains moments entre ces îles où
c'est un petit peu dans un contexte type
caraïbes ou bahamas à l'époque l'actuel
les dinosaures qu'on a trouvé en
normandie ont voyagé mais en fait il
était en bord de mer c'est des animaux
qui étaient qui devait vivre donc sur
les îles sur le pourtour des îles et en
fait j'ai bien rigolé avec ça avec les
normands parce que j'en ai expliqué que
leur les dinosaures normand soi-disant
les dinosaures carnivores normand
effectivement un armand dit est
complètement sous l'eau est en fait
étaient des dinosaures breton qui
vivaient sur le massif centre le massif
armoricain et qui se sont déposées sur
sur la côte et la côte se trouve être se
trouve être la norme en ont en fait
c'est des écosystèmes c'est un peu des
mangroves type mangrove actuelle donc
les dinosaures devait évoluer dedans ça
explique aussi le fait que sénégal aux
orres était sans doute pour la plupart
d'entre eux pas des carnivores au sens
strict du terme mais devait être aussi
piscivores donc une adaptation très
spécifiques on va retrouver en fait chez
leurs descendants les spinosaures et en
fait ça deslongchamps la très très bien
montée andy ont montré en 1837 ça a été
complètement oubliée donc quand on voit
tous les tous les papiers qui sort sur
les api sivori des spinosaures je
l'avait rappelé dans le papier de 2002
qui re décrivait pourri qui dope le
rhône mais en fait des longs champs en
1837 dans la salle super monographie de
2 po et kg + rhône avait déjà remarqué
qu au milieu d'un des blocs qui
contenait les gars strahl ya donc les
côtes abdominale et la cage thoracique
de l'animal il y avait sans doute les
restes du contenu stomacal et ceyreste
ça comprenez des tirs s des petites
dents de requins et des restes de
poissons qui avait un aspect rouille et
donc en fait des non choix très
justement déjà cette époque des cris se
serre est comme comme le contenu stomach
que donc par extension s'il n'y a pas
que les spinosaures qui était piscivores
chez les dinosaures mais leur leurs
ancêtres avaient déjà quelques petites
adaptations puisque le crâne des
mégadoses ores et déjà très allongée et
donc les mégalos szohr était déjà en
partie probablement piscivores il ya 160
millions d'années on a des spinosaures
en france comme tu parti étudier au
maroc j'imagine
voir pas mal de spinosaures là bas alors
moi c'est surtout les spin o du laos qui
m'intéressait puisque en fait on a par
des dents pendant très longtemps on
connaissait rien donc j'ai eu la chance
de tomber sur un bosquet let et puis
là-bas je suis normalement j'espère
d'ici un an ou on pourra publier la
suite puisque en fait on a couple le
squelette cervicales complet de l'animal
donc géré décrire le squelette axial il
ya quelques trucs assez marrant on a des
petites dents aussi mais malheureusement
on n'a pas trouvé le crâne
on a trouvé tout ce que la taxe si elle
n'est pas le crâne il ya il ya deux ans
quand on a on est retourné au laos et en
france non spinosaures pour l'instant il
ya des petites dents qui traîne à gauche
à droite mais on n'a pas encore trouvé
un [ __ ] ce véritable de spinosaures
donc on avait bon espoir ans jacques de
trouver les spinosaures parce que en
jacca été datée dans le papier de 2012 à
la dire à la fin du crétacé inférieur
donc au bar et miao terry bien et en
fait on se rend compte que grâce au
phone de carreaux fit quand jacques est
sans doute un petit peu plus vieux que
ça donc sans doute plutôt à la base du
crétacé inférieur donc au dessus de
chassiron et cherves mai mais pas aussi
haut dans la série stratigraphique et
glane date c'est à peu près ça fait
berrias bien donc on est à peu près à
140 millions d'années et à 140 millions
d'années
les restes de spinosaures
malheureusement toutes les danses
baryonyx qu'on connaît très très bien
dans le wild biens sont un peu plus
récente que ça donc si on vraiment vous
pouvez trouver des restes de spinosaures
à angeac ça serait sans doute les plus
vieux restes de spinosaures si on arrive
à démontrer que c'est bien du
spinosaures ça serait sans doute les
plus dur est de spinosaures qu'on
connaisse on connaisse en france mais
pour l'instant avec tout le travail
qu'on a fait je suis pas très très
optimiste sur le fait qu'on puisse se
trouver du spinosaures ans jacques
puisqu'on est parti sur angeac par
rapport au phone qu'on trouve au
jurassique ans jacques il ya déjà des
correspondances à ce qu'il en fait
en france beaucoup en train de préparer
justement cette exposition sur un jacky
on travaille en fait on va travailler
sur plus largement sur toutes les
découvertes qui ont été faites en
en charente c'est ces 15 dernières
années donc il ya trois grands gisements
il ya le gisement de charge de cognac
qui a été exploité par jean michel mazin
pendant pendant pas mal de temps
alors qui est un gisement qui est quand
même un contexte lagunaire
donc on a effectivement un espèce de bj
écologique et on a surtout à achat à
cherves qui est ce qu'il fait l'écho
cherves est intéressant c'est qu'on a
énormément de crocodile donc dû gôniots
police on a plus ou moins la même espace
à angeac et on a énormément de micro
reste dont des mammifères
après il ya un deuxième gisement un peu
plus récents qui exploité depuis par un
parent aussi de très nombreux collègues
et les gisements châssis ont donc c'est
dominique abit qui coordonne tout ça
donc chassiron c'est sur l'île d'oléron
et chassiron c'est pareil c'est plutôt
un environnement on va dire côtier mais
même si on est sur la côte puisqu'il ya
vraiment une
quelques quelques quelques on va dire
taxons qui sont clairement marin il ya
aussi des clairement des taxes ont
clairement continentaux comme des
amphibiens donc on sait qu'on a on est
on est sur la côte mais un endroit où il
ya des arrivées sans doute importante
lorsque c'est un fleuve je ne sais pas
trop quoi
mais voilà on a un contexte contexte
sédimentologiques continental qui est
quand même présent mais on n'a pas de
gros animaux non plus de très très gros
animaux comme on va en avoir un en
jacques et engins qu'en fait on est en
milieu beaucoup plus proximale et là on
va se trouver avec une faune qui est
complètement continental il ya très très
peu de deux marqueurs de milieu marin à
angeac il ya quelques brille aux
horaires et quelques quelques forums
mais c'est tellement peu par rapport à
toute la la masse de données qu'on a sur
les animaux continental que on est
vraiment mieux auxi ont grosso modo on a
trois gisements en charente qui se
suivent dans le temps et plus ou moins
dans l'espace on va dire que on à
chassiron qui est le plus vieux qui est
clairement jurassique après on va passer
à cherves qui est plus lagunaire et qui
est à la limite jurassique crétacé pas
sans doute la limite jurassique crétacé
avec le gisement de chair et après on va
avoir en jacques donc où là on est
beaucoup plus proximale et on devrait
mieux beaucoup plus continentale
ou plus riches en dinosaures il ya eu
des vidéos récemment sur je crois que
c'était sûr universcience oui parlait de
des plumes qu'on avait retrouvé dans
l'ambré aussi d'une en panne de plume
qui avait été retrouvé sur une sorte de
schiste ça vient de quelqu'un qui ment
ça alors ça les la plume dans l'ombre
c'est beaucoup plus récent c'est l'abc à
elle bien si je dis pas de bêtises parce
qu'il ya plusieurs yali atouts crétacé
en fait ya toute la série crétacé
inférieur qui et qui est représenté en
charente jusqu'au cénomanien est en fait
la charente en fait le renouveau c'est
surtout l'équipe de rennes donc didier
néraudeau romain vu l'eau vincent
perrichot qui travaille sur les
environnements de la fin du crétacé
inférieur et au départ tout a tourné
autour de la découverte dambre et
septembre pour l'instant malheureusement
si je ne dis pas de bêtises on la
connaît pas justement avant avant
l'action donc leur lambres plus vieux
qu'on connaisse en charente et haïtiens
et tout le monde aimerait retrouver
delambre du crétacé inférieur parce
qu'on a les conifères et on les a bien
en jacques sauf que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire pour l'instant on n'a pas du
tout dedans brd en cédant ces gisements
là donc les plumes retrouver en charente
sont beaucoup plus récentes
elles sont plutôt à 115 120 millions
d'années que le gisement d'angeac qui
lui est à 140 millions c'est pas des
plumes demi mot alors ça sera pas des
plumes de millau mais ça peut être des
plumes de dinosaures qui est déjà pas
mal mais de façon pour trouver le plume
de bimo ça va être
alors on a toujours possibilité à angeac
on a on a quand même un gisement
exceptionnel tant par la quantité que
par la qualité donc c'est en fait c'est
un la garde totale mais c'est un fois un
conservateur a girl leighton
et voilà donc on en a conservation et
puis aussi on a un nombre de fossiles
complètement hallucinant donc il n'est
pas impossible qu'un jour en démo tant
nos argile on ouvre des blocs d'argile
avec les mains et a pas besoin de gros
outils il n'est pas impossible qu'un
jour on puisse tomber sur sur une
empreinte de de plume qui soit qui ait
laissé son empreinte dans les argiles la
même façon qu'on peut très bien trouver
des ailes d'insectes des choses comme ça
donc on désespère pas de ce côté là il
ya des oiseaux à l'époque il n'y a pas
de raison qu'il en ait pas dans notre
dans notre faune dans les micros reste
contrairement à cherves où il avait
repéré des petites dents d'archaeopteryx
il est né on n'a pas encore trouvé ça à
angeac on a une micro faune très très
abondante on a nous aussi trouver tout
un tas de mammifères aujourd'hui mais on
n'a pas encore pu montrer avec certitude
qu'on avait des dents qui pourraient
être attribués à des oiseaux d'accord
que tadic conservateur lager stefan ça
veut dire qu'il ya de trouver des des
restes de contenus stomacaux de plus
mais tout ça c'est alors voilà bon et
puis déjà faut en terme de conservation
on a souvent tendance à oublier que tous
ces beaux gisements de dinosaures à
plumes en chine
on les appelle conservateur à garges
totale parce qu on conserve des choses
assez extraordinaire comme les plumes
mais il faut savoir que le problème de
ces gisements en chine c'est que les
plumes sont peut-être bien conservé mais
les l'escrinet tu ne le sont pas si
quand on étudie tous les dinosaures à
plumes en chine c'est très compliqué à
étudier parce que c'est quand même des
crêpes faut pas se cacher faut pas se
voiler la face
la plupart du temps les squelettes sont
très aplati on n'a pas accès la 3d et en
paléontologie quand on fait de la
morphologie
quand on n'a pas la 3d c'est vraiment
très compliqué et on peut très
rapidement et dans la surinterprétation
interprétation de certaines structures
donc voilà il faut se méfier quand on
parle de ces concerts devaient être
largage tonnes c'est vrai pour les
plumes ans jacques ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est la préservation des
eaux parce que nous on a des eaux en 3d
qui seront conservés les zones mimos ont
conservé de façon j'ai vraiment jamais
vu ça ailleurs
j'espère que dans le temps des gens qui
sont plus spécialisés dans la
morphologie fonctionnel prendront le
temps d'étudier les eaux demi mots pour
étudier toutes les attaches musculaire
parce qu'il ya un gros gros et beau
travail je pense à faire battre suite
tellement les on a deux d'éléments et de
petites de petits détails sur les eaux
que d'habitude on ne voit jamais sur les
os qu'on trouve dans des environnements
plus gréseux autres voilà on a cette
possibilité leur masse est ce déjà ceux
se ses eaux parfaitement conservés et on
a des petites choses aussi on a des
cuticules qui sont très bien préservé on
a des plantes qui sont très bien
préservés donc maintenant là ça sera
plus de la chance mais effectivement
rien ne nous empêche de penser qu'un
jour on peut trouver des plumes
fossilisées dans l'est dans les argiles
anges et alors
bah du coup au niveau de cette faune
d'angeac donc on connaît beaucoup le
mimo et puisqu'on puisqu'on parlait de
carnivore est ce qu'il y à pas est ce qu
il yad autres théropodes que le mimos
qu'on avait découvert d'autres
alors malheureusement non ça c'est le
seul c'est le seul problème que j'ai on
a une faune d'herbivores très complète
puisqu'on a on a un sauropode enfin on a
plusieurs spécimens mais d'une seule et
même espèce de sauropodes on a
maintenant je pense qu'ils ont le jean
est alors en ont bien parlé on a surtout
maintenant des stégosaure avec à la fois
les eaux et les empreintes ça aussi
c'est exceptionnel d'avoir des hauts et
des empreintes dans un même gisement je
crois qu'il n'ya pas y'a pas beaucoup
d'exemples dans le monde où on a ce type
de choses on a des iguanodon les ips
îlots faudon enfin que tata d'herbivores
on a donc de théropodes nominaux qui
était sans doute herbivores ou omnivore
on va dire et en carnivores on a des
tonnes de dents de théropodes on en a
vraiment beaucoup en avoir une
quarantaine ou une cinquantaine
facilement et on a un seul os qu'on a
trouvés l'année dernière donc la
dernière c'est vrai que j'avais eu un
petit coup de un petit coup ça bien
pulsé un moment je me suis dit ah enfin
des eaux de théropodes donc on a trouvé
une magnifique griffe en plus un os
assez emblématique donc on peut pas
tellement se tromper sur son son
interprétation donc on va trouver une
griffe de deux gros théropodes qui
qui était dans un contexte sédimentaires
un peu particulier en jacques c'est à
dire qu'on est de plus ou moins un
chenal est donc cette année l'idée ça a
été de creuser un petit peu plus en
avant ce chenal pour voir s'ils avaient
pas la suite de notre théropodes et d'un
manque de bol la ce a rien donné
par contre en poursuivant c'est là qu'on
va trouver tous les restes du frigo or
donc voilà donc on manque encore un peu
de théropodes à angeac avec les dents on
peut quand même dire qu'on a au moins
3,3 théropodes présent dans les
écosystèmes alentours donc on a un grand
théropode carnivore qui doit ressembler
aux néo venator anglais donc un
carcharodontosaures à la douceur idées à
l'os android on va dire on a des petites
dents très particulières qui sont
complètement asymétrique qui se
rapproche de déo tyrannus donc et/ou
tyrannus a été décrit comme peut-être un
tyranneau soro i primitif donc ça on a
angers qu'on a c'est dans vraiment très
très particulière qu'on connaît ailleurs
en europe
et puis on a aussi ses petites dents
aussi qu'ils sont bien caractérisée qui
rappelle un taxon qui a été décrit à
très longtemps aussi que qu'elle était
appelée nude et s et qui serait sans
doute d'une rom et aux orres donc on
sait qu'on a trois carnivores ou moins
avec sans doute des morphologies très
différentes mais pour l'instant
malheureusement ça ne reste que des
restes dentaire ça va nous permettre
d'aller quand même très très loin et on
est toujours à la recherche de restes
post crânien ou même crânien de
théropodes et là aussi c'est pareil on
est très très loin d'avoir fini de
fouiller ans jacques et rien ne nous dit
que la même façon que c'est que vous
aurez très localisés dans la carrière
rien ne nous dit que dans l'année
prochaine dans trois ans dans quatre ans
je ne sais pas en étendant les fouilles
on ne puisse pas tomber sur sur des
restes d'un dinosaure carnivore
mais pour l'instant c'est pas le cas
dans cette liste de d'affinités
potentiel de ces carnivores yahia et au
tyrannus qui m'évoque plus tôt l'asie
c'est ça ne me trompe pas et aux tirs
venant à leur nom et au tyrannus avait
été décrit en angleterre
or par contre c'est vrai que les plus
vieux tirano soro i dare
pendant un moment on a trouvé les plus à
tirano soro ide en asie effectivement ça
a été la découverte du liaoning avec
groen longue 10 langues et tout ça sauf
que quand on a trouvé c'est ces
gisements là on s'est rendu compte qu'en
europe on avait des des animaux qui leur
ressemblait et en parquet tuer un animal
qui est connu en angleterre depuis la
fin du 19ème siècle qui s'appelle procès
vente aux russes et qui a été réétudié
par mon collègue olivier un raout à
munich la qui a travaillé avec les le
british museum et donc oliver allait
retravailler y avait montré que sigouin
longuet et dix longues sont vraiment les
tyranneaux soro id bas procès rate aux
russes en est aussi un probablement bon
après que ces trois actions soit
vraiment la base des tyranneaux soro il
je pense que moi d'un point de vue
personnel je pense qu'il ya peut-être
encore des il va falloir aller un petit
peu plus loin dans les analyses pour
prouver de façon ferme et définitive
disons que c'est pas un résultat que je
prends comme comme comme vraiment
définitif à 100% par contre ce que tu ce
que tu dis sur les faunes asiatiques
c'est assez intéressant parce que
effectivement s'est rendu compte que on
avait pas mal de points communs
finalement entre nos faune d'angeac et
d'asie on a des accents qui sont communs
on allait on allait quand s'appelle les
en italie mother déjà alors on sait qu'à
cette époque là bas il y en a justement
donc tu trouve actuellement en afrique
du sud puisqu'il ya une côte basse russe
qui a été écrit il ya quelques années
qui qui serait le moins des plus jeunes
et aux dinosaures on aura peut-être
inquiète encore encore plus vieux à
angeac et puis on sait surtout que sinon
tous les autres en italie mother
cognitifs sont connus en asie donc ça
met en évidence des relations sans doute
assez étroite entre entre l'asie et
l'europe à cette époque là et dans une
moindre mesure aussi sans doute entre
l'europe et l'afrique
il ya cette action là il ya aussi des
taxons de ptérosaure qui ne sont comme
vaincus à l'europe et à l'asie aide et
action de mammifères
et puis il ya des taxons qu'ils ont une
répartition beaucoup plus vastes comme
on va dire ben hammam les stégosaures
qui sont bien connues en europe mais on
connaît aussi et en chine et en amérique
du nord
il faudrait qu'on précise un petit peu
lors des monographies qui sortiront sur
les animaux d'angeac concon précise
vraiment les relations de chaque animal
pour l'instant le seul truc sur lequel
on est sûr c'est qu'on a une tortue qui
est très proche de la firme anglaise
donc de pelures au sternum et on est
quasiment sûr aussi que notre grand
sauropode est sans doute très très
étroitement apparentées si c'est pas la
même chose mais apparemment c'est un
petit peu différent du tueur yaz au
russe qui a été décrit en espagne par
raphaëlle rubio torres qui moud file un
coup de main chaque année sur le cadre
d'accords donc une une faune proche de
l'asie mais rattaché un petit peu à
l'afrique
ça rappelle un peu ce qui se passe au
fait à ses supérieurs dans l'europe
entière aux portes de carrefour en fait
ce qu'est ce qui est plus intéressant
dans cette histoire là c'est surtout
vers l'europe comme carrefour de faune
en fait je pense que c'est l'europe est
restée un carrefour des faunes pendant
tout le mésozoïque on l'a on l'a montré
récemment aussi pour le trias puisque
avec maxime de bus que re qui a
retravaillé l'étudiant qui a retravaillé
sur la faune de mammifères de
saint-nicolas-de-port on a montré qu'on
avait du medgaz austro dont quelque
chose qui existe aussi en afrique du sud
donc on montre déjà que l'europe était
étant carrefour donc magasin straudo
morganucodon des animaux qui sont au
carrefour entre afrique europe et asie
on a pu montrer aussi après que au
jurassique moyen finalement les faunes
de mégalo soro id les mégalos szohr
était présente à peu près partout dans
le monde
donc on est à l'origine de tous ces
groupes là donc je pense qu'on va de
plus en plus dans des des faunes qui
sont en fait très uniformément répartis
pendant on va dire tout le trias
jurassique inférieur et jurassique moyen
et petit à petit on va voir des
endémisme plus ou moins marqué parce
qu'on a des fois quand même très
particulière en asie on assez m'amène
cheese aurait souri dès qu'ils sont
quand même très particulier
ces grands se repose avec un coup
incroyablement à manger mais c'est vrai
qu'on attend très longtemps postulé une
un isolement de l'asie pendant le
jurassique supérieur crétacé inférieur
et l'asie n'est peut-être pas aussi
isolé qu'on a voulu le dire et on a sans
doute des des relations qu'on pourrait
envisager entre asie et europe
à cette époque là par contre fait à ses
succès vrai que là on a un endémisme on
va dire un peu plus marqué l'europe est
vraiment redevenu un archipel à ce
moment-là et l'europe en fait est un
espèce de mélange de saône africaine
asiatique enfin je crois qu'on a encore
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de questions
à se poser sur le crétacé supplée
européen
le problème c'est qu'on sait pas si
c'est l'europe qui va distribuer les
dinosaures un peu partout dans le monde
ou si c'est les dinosaures d'un peu
partout dans le monde qui vont se
retrouve en europe quoi qu'il en soit la
faune du crétacé supérieur d'europe la
faune de dinosaures du crétacé supérieur
d'europe
elle est très très compliqué à mon sens
à comprendre d'un point de vue la
paléographie c'est plus facile au
jurassique et au crétacé où on se rend
compte que finalement il ya pas mal des
changes encore possible
transcontinentaux je vais me permettre à
un petit plaisir mini hors sujet parce
que tu as parlé des mammifères moi
c'était notre 100e vidéo ce matin donc
voilà je me permets un cadeau
d'anniversaire un bel article et qui est
en sorti alors je sais pas si vous
l'avez si vous l'avez aussi puisque
c'est internationale dans pour la
science la ya un article de style blues
à ty et xylio qui est sorti sur
justement la diversité des mammifères
mésozoïque donc ça fait plaisir de voir
ça arrive au niveau du public parce que
ça fait quand même quelques années qu'on
est quand même plusieurs à dire que les
mammifères mésozoïque mérite beaucoup
plus et beaucoup mieux que ce que ce
qu'on leur offre à l'heure actuelle il
ya quand même eu tout un tas de
de découverte assez extraordinaire fait
en chine mais il ya aussi tout un tas
d'autres matériels qu'il faut reprendre
battant c'est quelque chose en toi même
donc voilà c'est bien que des gens
repartent et continue à explorer cette
branche là il faudrait plus de monde il
faudrait plus de monde sur le terrain
surtout ici pour aller chercher parce
que je pense qu'il ya des découvertes
magnifique et on va se rendre compte que
en fait là l'histoire des mammifères est
beaucoup plus complexe que ce qu'on nous
a raconté pendant pas mal d'années
pendant nos études on nous expliquait
que toute façon pendant le mésozoïque
tous les mammifères c'était laid mais et
aides étaient tous plus ou moins pareil
et que la véritable radiation des
mammifères apparaît à la disparition des
dinosaures
je pense qu au jurassique moyen ya une
radiation des manifs hier qui est
colossal et qu'il ya une diversité sans
doute plus abondante
même si effectivement il n'y avait pas
de très très gros animaux mais je pense
que l'avenir est aux mammifères
mélodique
du coup il ressemble à quoi les
mammifères dort jacques ory les
mammifères d'angeac pour l'instant on
n'a pas beaucoup d'éléments rien
d'extraordinaire on en a quelques uns
quand même on a on a des multi
tubercules et donc on a on a trouvé ya
deux ans c'était assez assez sympa
bateau tu connais peut-être bien ça mais
peut-être pas tous les auditeurs les
militaires reculer il ya une prémolaires
quelle espèce de forme de rebondir de
scie circulaire on va dire et donc on a
retrouvé une prémolaires de ces multi
tubercules et donc ça c'est sympa parce
que c'était une pièce exceptionnelle et
puis qu'il donne tout de suite le groupe
auquel on a affaire
et sinon on a quand même aussi quelques
quelques quelques dents qui sont plus de
formes tricot nos dont tu donc des
mammifères un peu plus complexe alors
maintenant on n'a pas encore été assez
dans le détail pour savoir à quel groupe
on a à faire mais on a déjà au moins
quatre ou cinq packs sont différents de
mammifères ans jacques rien qui se
rapprochent pour l'instant des terriens
mai
voilà ça arrivera peut-être dans un
avenir proche on continue à travailler
tranquillement sur sur le micro on a
déjà tamisée je prends environ pas loin
de sept ou huit tonnes de sédiments
après ce qui est très long c'est loterie
alors là on a de la chance on a
quelqu'un angoulême
gilles bailly qui nous aide vraiment il
est prof de sport mais aussi aux
paléontologues amateurs et et quand il a
un moment il se précipite au musée
d'angoulême et il nous fait du tri elle
c'est lui qui est en train de petit à
petit de de nous constituer toute la
microfaune d'angeac et ça va être ça va
être plutôt sympa chance
cc du petit ce mammifère cdu et 7 ça est
vraiment ces ouvriers ou d'une
musaraigne ça ouais voilà c'est pas bon
mais on est sûr détails
ça c'est pour les cd et s'est même déjà
j'ai envie de dire quasiment pour les
plus gros mais oui ça reste ça reste des
mammifères de petite taille et pour
l'instant on n'a que des dents mais
c'est pareil hein faut pas oublier qu'on
est toujours dans le on est toujours
dans la possibilité à un moment sur une
lentille ou sur quelque chose d'un peu
particulier au niveau d'angeac de tomber
sur des restes beaucoup plus complet
d'un de ces petits animaux
d'accord je précise ça t'a parlé de
terriens donc pour ceux qui connaissent
pas terrien ça veut pas dire qu'on
s'attend à trouver des mammifères
extraterrestre ça veut juste dire que
s'ils appartiennent au groupe démarre
sous x qui englobe les marsupiaux et les
placentaire petite dernière question car
on arrive on est déjà à quarante cinq
minutes à peu près petite dernière
question tu as évoqué tout à l'heure une
exposition aurejac est ce que c'est
est ce que c'est possible de nous en
parler ou est ce que c'est encore
confidentiel alors non c'est pas du de
confidentiel au contraire il faut que çà
çà çà sortent des cartons parce qu'on va
voir son autre besoin den s'il peut être
pris un petit peu tard et on devrait
quand même y arriver donc c'est un navet
la bénévole
c'est un appel à bénévoles un appel aux
dons un appel à tout ce que vous voulez
donc grosso modo on a on s'était dit
qu'après six ans ou sept ans bah comme
le public me suis quand même très
largement depuis le début puisqu'on a
toujours fouillées j'ai envie de dire
vu su de tout le monde donc tout le
monde tout le monde peut voir qu'on fait
tout le monde peut nous suivre pour ceux
qui veulent il ya un excellent en 53
minutes qui lit encore sortir donc qui
était sortie sur une plateforme qui
s'appelle comic strip qui suivait ans
jacques est en fait donc nicolas albert
là vous avez filmé l'année dernière il
avait déjà fait un 52 minutes sur les
traces de mazan notre dessinateur et
c'est tellement pris au jeu cette année
il a décidé de venir revenir nous voir
et refile mais hélas le le fil de la
campagne 2016 et est en ligne donc sur
sur comic strip donc vous retrouverez
bas un petit peu les gens que vous avez
vous avez interviewé l'autre jour donc
laure jean mois jean-françois tant de
puissance - tout le monde et surtout
avec les images de la campagne de flux
donc voilà donc ça c'est pour la partie
voilà je fais notre petite pub met donc
on va on a décidé aussi de faire ça tu
avais cette exposition donc cette
exposition la paix même reçu un label
national du ministère de la culture donc
on est en train de la montée donc l'idée
c'est de présenter ces faux nez
dinosaures de charente dont je parlais
tout à l'heure donc les faunes pas que
de langeac mais aussi de chassiron et et
de cherves de les présenter de les
remettre en contexte de montrer un petit
peu toutes les découvertes qu'on a fait
nous les remettre en contexte on va dire
global parce que la paléontologie local
c'est intéressant mais ce qui est
surtout intéressant c'est que les faunes
qu'on a trouvé dans ces dans ses
gisements nous renseigne sur toute
l'évolution de nos groupes
donc ça s'arrête pas au niveau au niveau
charente et est donc là on travaille sur
tout un tas de choses différentes donc
il va y avoir un livre dont il ya tout
un tas de collègues tout un tas de
paléontologues français qui vont qui ont
participé à l'écriture de cet ouvrage
donc ça sera un gros livre de 150 à 200
pages je pense et puis on travaille sur
l'exposition donc il ya plusieurs
plusieurs éléments on va essayer de
reconstituer au moins une grosse pacte
votre grand dinosaure donc une pâte qui
devrait faire quand même dans les 5
mètres de haut à peu près donc là on a
ouvert pour nous aider à faire ça on a
ouvert
une plateforme de crowdfunding donc sur
balles benneteau n'est donc si les gens
veulent nous aider on prend voilà je
crois qu on avoue on a demandé jusqu'à
8000 euros pour pouvoir se faire
travailler des mouleurs qui vont nous
faire une reconstitution de cette pâte
là en parallèle moi je suis en train de
travailler avec mon collègue au muséum
florent goussard sur la reconstruction
en 3d d'un seul être complet dans lie to
me moser donc on a terminé
j'allais dire aujourd'hui mais en fait
ce sera demain parce qu'on a encore
quelques petits trucs à faire est donc
maintenant on va aussi des démarches et
les des des compagnies qui font du
l'impression 3d puisque un niveau qui va
faire à peu près 3 mètres de long sur 1
mexes et 50 de hauteur à prototyper
sachant qu'on veut prototype et toutes
les pièces une pareille donc un
squelette complet saclay plus de plus de
200 pièces
ça coûte quand même 25 mille euros donc
là on est en train de travailler surtout
la tête avec un partenariat de notre
institution donc du muséum
mais voilà on est on est on a aussi fait
appel à des mécènes locaux puisque on a
tout un tas de deux personnes de
l'entreprise qui nous aident quand on
est en charente que ce soit les carriers
les viticulteurs ou autre on a tout un
tas de gens derrière nous ou alors vous
avez ce projet continue à rester un
projet très très ouvert au public et
donc on espère pouvoir remonter cette
expo donc cette expo a là un avenir pas
encore complètement défini mais elle
sera au moins présentes pendant six mois
l'année prochaine angoulême après elle
va voyager à la rochelle après il faut
que j'en discute avec des collègues
étrangers savoir s'il ya des gens qui
veulent se mettre sur les rangs d'un des
contacts avec avec des avec la suisse
avec les belles gens qu'il faut qu'on
voie un petit peu et on espère qu'elle
viendra finalement au muséum en 2019 en
2020 et donc on pourrait la présenter à
un public le plus large possible
voilà donc reconstituer ses iphone du
crétacé inférieur et remettre ça rend en
contexte paléontologique il ya tout un
tas d'histoires à raconter puisqu'on a
on a vraiment énormément énormément
d'amis donc si tout se passe bien enfin
normalement sais pas si tu n'aimes pas
si tout se passe bien tout va bien se
passer
ça va être dur mais
on devrait inaugurer angoulême au mois
de mai l'année projet d'accord donc
chers auditeurs le lien vers la vidéo
comic strip et le crowfunding seront
dans la description des voix là et fait
passer sur les réseaux sociaux
s'il y en a qui sont passionnés de
paléontologie c'est vrai que vous êtes
la plateforme idéale pour pour faire de
la pub un petit peu partout parce que
c'est pas toujours évident de mettre de
mettre les personnes au courant mais
voilà c'est vrai que la moindre petite
est que je peux faire pour me rade et
des pelles reconstruction de dinosaures
à l'arrivée parce que pour reconstruire
ce squelette complet demi mots vous êtes
obligé de quoi de scanner
individuellement chaque pièce alors
voilà ce qu'on a fait c'est que on
voulait pas faire une sculpture
parce que finalement on veut rester le
plus scientifique possible
donc en fait depuis 2010 qu'on trouve du
mi mots il faut savoir qu'on est
aujourd'hui à entre 2500 et 3000
éléments squelettiques demi mots qui
sont qui ont été découverts donc on a la
chance que tous ces gens ont été
préparés
je me préparais c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment nickel après moi mon travail ça
consiste évita d'identifier donc à des
choses c'est facile comme d'identifier
un fémur par contre les vertèbres
ils sont pas dans l'ordre donc on a près
de 45 bertacco dame si verte est sacré
12 vertèbres dorsales et 10 vertèbres
cervicales
quand il faut les remettre dans le bon
ordre pour reconstituer un squelette si
on va faire une reconstitution la plus
scientifique possible ça a pris beaucoup
beaucoup de temps donc voilà ça on l'a
fait et donc on est parti du matériel
vraiment d'angeac donc toutes les pièces
ont été scannées en 3d c'était un scan
simplement surfacique et une fois qu'on
en a eu l'escale en 3d comme on a au
moins 40 individus différents dans le
bonne bête d'angeac le gros travail
aussi ensuite ça a été de les remettre à
l'échelle puisqu'on avait des animaux
qui étaient de taille différente donc ça
aussi ça implique et tout un tas de
voyage pour aller voir des autres ni
tommy moe szohr fond de toi tu attires
tout un tas d'études pour pouvoir faire
cette mise à échelle est donc
aujourd'hui on a terminé on peut
proposer un squelette quasi complet
alors il nous manque un petit peu
la partie avant du crâne malheureusement
et puis quelques os qu'on a pas on a
toujours ce problème cette histoire
incroyable avec les mains demi mots
qu'on n'a toujours pas trouvé mais pour
le reste voilà on a un spectre complet
qui est maintenant fait en 3d et qui va
être prototype et donc chaque pièce va
être imprimé en 3d de façon indépendante
c'est-à-dire qu'on veut pas avoir des
gros blocs et après on fera un
surmoulage de ces pièces est ce qu'on
voudrait dans un deuxième temps c'est
faire plusieurs tirages de ces
squelettes pour pouvoir essayer de
proposer au public une reconstruction
d'un semblant de troupeaux au moins
trois ou quatre individus ont des
positions différentes
donc voilà ça c'est assez le but à jouer
tu sais pas si on pourra le faire en
moins d'un an mais déjà ce qu'on
voudrait c'est à voir notre prototypage
demi mot et on a tout ce qu'il faut pour
le faire
maintenant il nous manque un petit peu
un petit peu de fond mais j'espère que
ça va se débloquer d'ici la fin d'année
d'accord dans tout cas vous avez tout
notre soutien on va on va partager tout
ça sur la toile et bah merci au bout bon
et puis bon on vous souhaite aussi
beaucoup de beaucoup de chance et de
courage pour monter tout ça parce que
c'est en plus de tes cours et en plus de
la gestion des collections ça fait quand
même une quantité colossale de travail
ça crée beaucoup de travail mais bon
voilà rien on est quand on est plusieurs
sur des projets ça permet d'avancer et
puis bon ça reste c'est pas le travail
le plus le pire qui existent je pense
donc voilà on même si des français en
allant on le fait plutôt de bon coeur
bon bah merci beaucoup d'avoir participé
à cette interview j'espère qu'on aura
l'occasion d'en refaire une pour la
découverte ou des bras demi mots de de
mieux rabat si on découvre les mains
demi mots on ferait enfin un truc
internationale je pense qu'on fera une
communication à tout les toutes les
grandes chaînes parce que ça sera
tellement incroyable que non mais vous
vous expliquera tout sur les mains
demi-mot bientôt et vous expliquera
pourquoi on les a pas trouvé d'accord il
ya une raison à ça oui
attendez on les a probablement trouvé on
n'arrive pas à les identifier c'est
parce qu'on a des paléontologues qui
sont peut-être passé brillant sur place
mais bon on dira pas
voilà ok on va merci beaucoup merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi et je vous dis
à très bientôt